um thanks for coming back for our last
session now and so right now we'll have
is it Devon hobble the trophy almost
cool speaking about applied mixed
integer programming beyond the arc yeah
okay so kind of you can everyone hear me
all right so hi I'm Pablo I'm from
operational research team in Google and
today I'm going to talk about applied
mixed integer programming so this is
going to be a light weighted
practitioners perspective on how do we
use MIPS to solve real-life problems so
actually it fits in nicely to the
previous presentation it continues on
the similar sub sub sub subjects so the
subtitles beyond the optimum to fit
nicely within the workshop sub subject
however i was actually entertaining a
bit of a different twist before the
optimum because the main idea behind the
talk is that you know maps are np-hard
but then be hard because if you consider
looking for the optimum however in
practice we almost never care about
finding the optimum about proving the
optimum so this talk is going to be
about everything that happens before you
find the optimum so the outline is
pretty straightforward the talk is
partitioned two parts in the first one
I'm going to give you a practitioners
perspective why do we use mix so why are
there useful and you know they intuitive
answer might be that they allow you to
optimize a system or a product and be
more efficient however there are many
other benefits of using mix integer
programming and I will be focusing on
two of them one is the engineering
benefits and the other one is that while
they simply work and this will nicely
lead us to the second part of the talk
which is why do maps work why can we
solve efficiently problems in practice
at the very end I'm going to also talk a
bit about like self-criticism to give
you a bit more perspective on the
subject so that you can also judge
whether everything what I said is true
or not so let's start so why do we use
MIPS so um first of all how do you solve
problems when you're a software engineer
so you have to gather your input you
have to think think think
and you figure out that algorithm you
implemented the algorithm produces the
output and this outputs corresponds to
actions and the real world now this is
imperative programming because you have
to think what you need and you also need
to think how to get it so you need to
you know order the machine you need to
implement the algorithm now there is an
alternative approach of solving problems
which is declarative programming and
here you do not have to implement the
algorithm you just state what you want
so you create the model and then there
is a black box Oliver which is at your
disposal which will solve the model for
you so from engineering perspective this
is a beautiful property because it it
really reduces the effort for the
engineer to solve a problem so what kind
of things you can do with MIPS so this
probably all know this is just ensure we
are all on the same page so this is amit
right you have in matrix form and this
is a standard text book form form
formulation you have a vector of
variable x these are non-negative you
have linear inequalities d constraints
you optimize some of some objective and
for some of the variables or all of them
you can specify whether the variables
must only take integer values personally
I prefer a bit more extended version
these two are equivalent I mean the
direction of the optimization doesn't
matter because minimizing is just
maximizing the negative the offset in
the objective doesn't matter because it
just translates the entire space and in
practice you can actually specify the
lower and upper bounds for all of the
linear constraint and for all of the
variables and by the way this is not
need to be finite so you could use
infinity as the upper or lower bound so
this is what you have at your disposal
and you look at this and you might think
okay this is not that this is not a lot
so what kind of problems can be solved
with this and actually turns out there
are a lot of practical applications of
MIPS so just to give you a rough
intuition how such work is executed so
imagine that you have a knapsack problem
to solve right so you have items you
have bins and you have resources so this
is like a multi-dimensional multi
knapsack and you want to pick items to
put in the bins such that two Maxima
is dividing so what is your input you
have the value for each item or maybe
lets me use this we have the value for
each item you have also the size of each
item on each resource and you also have
how big is the bin on each of the
resources so then of course for each
combination of the item in the bay and
you have a binary decision whether to
choose it or not so what kind of
constraints you have well for our items
you might pick each item at most once
and of course every item must fit in the
bed and if you run this across the
objective that you want to maximize the
value of what you have this is this is
basically a multiline multi-dimensional
novel multi-dimensional knapsack from
this software engineer perspective you
know this is very short very secure is
very very nice and then what happens is
that you know the client for whom you
implemented this comes in and tells you
well you know but really we don't need a
knapsack what we really want we it's
more like bin packing so you know
instead of values we actually have some
number of copies for each items and we
just want to find something which fits
so now if you're a software engineer you
need to rewrite your entire code but if
you are using a map you just change like
30 letters and it works again then of
course situation repeat somebody comes
in and tells you well it's not only that
we want to place items in the bins we
also want to spread them evenly across
different bins so okay nothing simpler
you just add an additional variable
which I call surplus he'll hear the
surplus variable where will count the
surplus of items in each bins so what is
the expected number of items it's just
the sum of all items divided by the
number of bins so this is the
expectation minus what you actually
place there and you upper bound it from
above with the surplus variable which
you minimize if you do this then you
will actually find a placement of items
in bins which spreads them nicely across
different bins then somebody comes in
and tells you well you know it's not
only about the average surplus in each
in each of the bins we actually care
more about the max surplus select the
long
and this is the first objective we
really want to minimize so again nothing
simpler you add yet another variable you
bound all of the surplus variables of
this another one and you again minimize
I mean you add this to the objective and
now you have two components in the
objective and you differentiate them
between them with some sort of high high
high high number you solve this you have
now a nice packing problem and perhaps
at the very last stage the client comes
back again and says okay but you know
this is actually a real system which
which works in real world so usually we
already have some placement and now what
we want we want to spread the items but
we want to introduce us little change as
possible so again you just get another
data which is the number of items which
are already placed and you add
additional variables which will track
the difference between what the solver
decides and what was already there and
you add this to the objective and you
know if you combine this all in like no
10 lines you have a model which solves a
multi-dimensional multi-building with
balancing of items with reducing the
long tail and minimizing the change of
the current state so all of this means
that it's very easy to add new features
and it's a great property of you know
approaching problems it's very easy to
maintain its very sure it's very nice
and you know the language itself of of
MIPS is very minimalistic because you
only have the variables linear
constraints and the objective but it's
very expressible has showed you the
example of the of the bin bin bin
packing but this extends to many other
like a resource allocation scheduling
anything you think of you can be
expressed as a map ok this would not
mean anything if we couldn't really
solve the problems if we really couldn't
solve this kind of models that I showed
you in practice this is a slide I
borrowed from Professor bursting of
stock at this year you're sorry at this
year euro conference so in there isn't
2530 years there was a tremendous
progress in mep solving so if you count
the speed-up of solvers
there was around 1.5 million times
speedup in 30 years and this does not
account for hardware speed up hardware
speed up is yet another 500,000 so if
you combine this all its around you know
one trillion times speed up so this
means that something that took like a
month 30 years ago now takes less than
less than 10 a second now of course this
is averaged and it's not quite true for
all of the models but this gives you the
general idea how much the field has
improved and only because of that we can
actually use lips in practice so how
does a typical yes it has it as my speed
up in nonlinear optimization this I
don't know so how does a typical
progress of solving a model looks like
so this is um this is taken from from
really data of a model of about 200,000
variables 50,000 constraints about half
million non zeros so the red line is the
so-called incumbent so this is the best
solution found so far the the blue line
is the bounce so it's the it's we know
that we cannot do any better and this is
yet another nice property of MIPS they
give you the bound so whenever you have
your solution which is not yet the
optimum use you know how far from the
optimum you are at the worst case so
this is the time scale here so usually
what you see is that there is some
number crunching in the beginning for
few seconds then for let's say 23
minutes there is a very rapid progress
of the objective value and then it kinda
plateaus and you know you can even wait
up to a day or more to actually prove
that what you have is optimal so that's
why I'm saying that we don't really wait
for the optimum so now this was already
talked about in the previous
presentations a bit assume that the
light blue and light red is the less
accurate model meaning that this is the
model which was created using less
accurate data now imagine that
you have now the possibility to enhance
your your model with more accurate data
and then what happens very often is that
they you know did the the actual
solution which you get it gets improved
because you have better data you have
better knowledge of the like your model
represents the real world better so in
terms of like true objective you are
better off and the thing is that very
often it pays off to work on the model
to work on the quality of data because
this gives you a bigger improvement than
trying to optimize to optimality you're
less accurate model so in that sense
what it means is that data quality or
like model quality is more important
than proving the optimum in practice
however of course we still need this
very rapid progression very rapid
improvement if we want to have a good
quality solution very very fast so there
is still a question how can we get the
solution of high quality fast yes
the damage is also filed you're not over
50 and it really reflects the quality of
the modern 40 I mean this is like
problem specific in the sense that so
the question is was how do we how do we
assess the quality of the of the optimal
oh so this is let's say problem specific
in the end there are like matrix of the
system which are not necessarily in the
model but which measure and monitor the
system and which give you an intuition I
mean which give you an idea how well the
system behaves so then if you run your
model if you use one model to in your
system to produce some decisions you can
watch this external metrics and then you
can evaluate on that so of course this
that this does not extend into the
future in the sense that if the world
suddenly changes a lot then of course
your model might not know no longer be
accurate but yeah the running assumption
is that you know if you have a system it
should it should work in the same way in
the future as well otherwise it's it's
not very useful all right so yeah we
still need mipsel words to actually find
high quality solutions very very fast so
why are MIPS Oliver sufficient so very
quickly how does it move nips overworked
I guess that the most of you know this
stuff so first how to solve an LP so
this is the feasible polytope defined by
the linear constraints two variables so
this is the objective so the objective
is like control lines fake is bigger
value the objective thing is smaller we
want to minimize so the arrow points in
the direction so then the optimum lies
on the vertex there is a mathematical
theorem stating that an optimum always
lies on a vertex so how to find this
point notice that the linear system is
has infinitely many solutions it's like
the entire feasible polytope you can fix
some of the variables to zeros which
makes the system definite you solve the
linear system you get some point which
is a vertex and then there are rules how
to change your
a choice of which variables are fixed to
zeros which basically makes a jump over
the vertices up to the optimum and this
is in practice this is polynomial of
course not theoretically but in practice
it is now it makes situations a bit
different because now we are interested
only in integer points so I mean these
eight points and the optimum is here so
of course if you solve the relaxation
it's not in its that integer so how do
you solve this while you branch so you
basically do a branch and bound so I'm
split your problem in two in this
example you have x2 larger than 3 or X
to lower equal to and you saw the two
subproblems separately again the
relaxations are not integer but you can
continue at some point the relaxation
will be integer and at this point you
found your first incumbent it's not the
optimum yet the global optimum but it's
the first incumbent you can prune the
rest because you know that no better
solution will lie in here and you just
continue branching and eventually you
will find the optimum at the global
optimum so this is how it works so you
have branch and bound so this is the
third tree with some exemplary decision
in the beginning the red ones so every
circles like a mid node the red ones is
the infeasible the oranges the meat
feasible so it's the incumbent and then
you can prune something out if you if
you know that you can and in each node
you solve a simplex and it's basically
right so this doesn't really tell us why
we can solve MIPS efficiently it does
actually actually asks more questions
because this is branch and bound this is
like its financial research so why would
this work in practice so yeah why this
is efficient so this is efficient why
this is official we need to go back to
our progress plot there are actually
four different phases when solving a map
first one is pre-processing then there
is solving the road relaxation then
there is primal heuristics which has
nothing to do with research and then
there is finally did research and if you
look at the progress it doesn't always
go like this for all of the problems but
it's very very often kind of like this
the mark the the biggest progress is
done by promoter istics and then there
is still some significant progress done
by the tree search and then it plateaus
out in the end and this rapid progress
here is also enabled by by efficient for
processing in the beginning so there are
like gazillions of algorithms that that
goes into each of these phases I will
just explain some of them very very very
briefly to give you an idea that you
know em it's always like a collection of
different techniques which work together
to solve the problem so pre-processing
so clean up so this is the matrix a of
your problem it's it's always sparse
like I mean in practice it is always
sparse it's actually very very far as
always it's never danced so the clean up
the idea behind the clean up is to
basically it's like syntax analysis of
the equations to make them smaller so
you find you find columns which are
proportional and remove them you'll find
rose which are proportional and you
remove them you find variables which are
free and you remove them you substitute
them out and many many other things
eventually when you when you do this
after you you'll do this your original
problem from from big size becomes much
much smaller some other techniques to
pre-processing bound propagation so you
don't need to read this basically for
every constraint you can every
constraint has some bounce lower and
upper bound but you can also try and
third bounced from the variables which
are in the equation and from the bounds
of the variables which are in the
equation and this helps you to make your
bounce more strict there is a lot of
literature especially in constraint
programming on this how to do this
efficiently this helps because this
basically shrinks your feasible set to a
smaller one so you have less to explore
and if you have integer variables you
can also do some rounding up and down to
be even more aggressive inbound
propagation next there is probing so
probing is a technique where I will
on the example of binary variables so
probing basically means that you fix the
variable to zero then you fix the
variable to one you solve the linear
relaxation and hope that one of them
will turn out infeasible this is the
case then you know that the variable has
to be 0 in this case so you can fix it
and then you can clean up the model
again and remove it from the model
making it against smaller and you do it
many many times for many different
variables you do it at the beginning
ones to make this tool to make the model
smaller then there is cuts so cuts is a
very important topic I will not really
talk about it so cuts cutting planes
these are equations which you add to
your model which are always valid and
we'd shove off the fractional parts of
the feasible polytope so they all of the
integer points remain inside but you get
a better relaxation so like in this
example because if you could find these
two cards you would ask after solving
relaxation you would be already in the
optimum and there is a historically
speaking when cats were first proposed
they were not very efficient because the
way they were they were computed they
were the way they were adding a lot of
cuts and if you add cuts you make the
model bigger because you have more
equations in the model so this this has
a negative impact on the efficiency so
you have to find a sweet spot you want
to add few cuts which are good and this
is not this is not easy at all next so
now okay so this was about the
proportion yep so when people publish
new cuts or whatever I mean do they
prove theorem saying this will this is
this is theoretically better than this
for some reason or is it experimental
table says
it's usually an experimental paper but
there is theory goes more like into
let's say taxonomy in the sense that
people show that for example some cuts
which were proposed 20 years ago they're
actually members of some bigger cuts
family which could be generalized and
parameterized and then maybe you have a
you know it gives this more info on how
does dee de dee how could you classify
different types of cuts but I don't
think there are theoretical a lot of
theoretical results which show that you
know the discard is really superior to
to that one usually it's going to be
superior on some types of problems and
not on the others so most of the paper I
mean in the end many papers are
empirical because they implement this in
an Apes Oliver try to run it and then
evaluate how it works on on the range of
different problems and the procedures
are not complete or are they what do you
mean by that like is it guaranteed to
always I mean this approval it reaches
the optimum always oh so I mean so so so
I procedure so yeah so okay i'm not i'm
not certain about this but i think that
there is a proof that at least for for
some cuts you could have you could have
an algorithm without the branch and
bound which only basis on adding the
cuts and it is complete but it is less
efficient than the branch on body
so how about the relaxation so how do we
solve the the LP relaxation so this
already i showed you that how to jump
over the vertices so i'm not an expert
on this so just just just just you know
put this very very vaguely here matrix a
is sparse so the entire implementation
of the revised simplex realize on that
and it doesn't really make the matrix
dense it always keeps it in a sparse
form and because of that it's very very
efficient and also the other part of the
solving the relaxation is that we use
so-called dual simplex which allows you
when you do the when you do when you
explore the search tree and you do the
other branch it's very easy if you have
the relaxation of your parent it's very
easy to find the relaxation of the Sun
it's just few changes to the basis of
the simplex and you can very quickly get
the solution so this is the reason why
for example revised simply the dual
simplex is used in mep solving in the
branch and bound because it's iterative
and you don't have to resolve from
scratch in every node then ok so this
was the pre-processing then was the root
relaxation and now the primal heuristics
so here are again some examples so for
example people and shift so this is a
heuristic which uses the simplex
machinery but it changes the the order
of exploring of jumping over the
vertices so the idea is that in the
revised simplex in the simplex if you
push out variables out of the basis you
fix them to their bounds so if you have
for example a binary variable which has
the zero and one lower and upper bound
respectively if you push it out from the
basis you're going to make it integer
because this is the bound so the idea
behind people and shift is to make such
pivots such jumping's on the feasible
polytope that will actually move not
towards the optimum but towards an
integer point so this will find you some
integer point that necessary
optimal but it will find you some
solution another primal holistic is
shipped in propagate so this is very
very easy it basically it's also called
diving so what you do you just do
branching and then you propagate the
bounds using the very very simple
machinery you do not use simplex and you
just do this and then you might end up
in an infeasible point but if you repeat
this enough time there is some chance
that you will get to the mid feasible
point which again is your new incumbent
which you can then use later next there
is a perma holistic called feasibility
pump so feasibility pump basis on the
idea that when you solve the root
relaxation you have the LP feasible
point now you can round it so we have
the integral point which is not
necessarily LP feasible anymore so then
if you have a procedure to go back to
feasibility you could repeat this this
this loop and many times in hold at some
point you know either this will be LP
feasible or this will be integer so how
do we do the rounding while running is
quite simple you just round very often
people add some stochasticity to it so
to ensure that the system does not cycle
and the pump is basically minimizing the
l1 norm with respect to the current
integral point and you repeat this
repeat this and at some point this is
the series of LP feasible points and an
integral points will converge and you
will have a mid feasible point so there
is also a slight nuance 2d to the method
which was proposed recently you can also
have a different objective where you
basically weight in the original
objective in hope that you will steer
the method a bit towards high quality
solutions
alright so this was about primal have
holistics now about the third tree so
this is pruning so the value in the node
is the value of the relaxation so here
it's nine the incumbent values five so
if you explore in this way then go back
and you know that the value of the
relaxation is five here you can prune
the rest of the of the tree because you
know that there can be no better
solution than five and you already have
five so it's okay however if for example
here divided of the rocks ation was four
then you cannot prove because four is
lower than than five so you have to
continue but do you have to well I mean
you have to investigate the the
objective and sometimes you can infer
from the coefficients and from the
integrality of the variables that the
objective for example the objective step
so the objective must always be improved
in some quantities so in here if its
larger than 1 it means that if you have
an incumbent of value 5 it means that if
you ever find a better solution the the
objective must be lower than four
because this step is 1 so it means that
in this case actually you could prune
here so this again goes into this that
you know you have to very carefully
analyze the entire model and in first
are such information that you can then
do proving more aggressively then there
is a question of branching so how to
branch so how how to choose which
variable 222 branch on there are many
different methods the most popular ones
from episode of ghost branching so what
you do at the beginning you assume that
every variable has its a probability one
of being branched on and then once you
branch and you have the information
about the value of the relaxations you
can induce from this what is the impact
of branching on a variable on the value
of the relaxation and you aggregate this
knowledge and then this this information
steers the selection of which variables
to branch in different parts of the tree
then there is strong branching strong
branching is usually done at the big
getting so in here you do not really
accumulate knowledge but you just try to
grant on everything you solve all the
relaxations and take this branch which
has the highest value of the objective
and then there is also something that's
called active constraint branching which
for each know when you when you want to
branch you compute the flux of the
constraints so this is the you check
whether the sum of the variables in the
constraint is at the bound if it's if it
is at the bound you say that the
constraint is active and you pick a
variable from such a constraint this
kind of makes sense because it means
that if you brand on the variable from
the active constraint you're going to
force a lot of propagation of the bounds
which will eventually make your search
tree well let's hide then there is
country propagation I think there's
going to be some talks about that as
well so when you branch so this is not
the value of the objective this is like
the the level of branching 1 2 3 when
you branch this actually propagate some
bounds and then eventually leads to
infeasibility so we have like a conflict
graph you can analyze this graph and
from this graph sometimes you can deduce
sparse sparse constraints which you can
add to your model which will help prove
more of the sub tree in the future and
then there is also the idea about the
neighborhood's so this is like using
heuristics inside the search tree so you
know instead of just branching here what
is done is that you take this node you
convert it to some sort of a sub make
problem and then you resolve this submit
so again there are many different
approaches one is called local branching
when you upper bound the bond distance
between your current relaxation and the
incumbent or you can use relaxation
induced neighborhood search where you
actually fix some of the variables to be
us in the incumbent and then solve them
it this is all in hope that if you do
this you will find quickly a
high-quality solution finally last but
not least there is parallelism
so there's ongoing work to make the
solvers distributed so if you have a
search tree you could search one of the
branch on one machine and other other
brand on the other machine and this is
now getting momentum I would say so to
summarize everything you know to
efficiently solve a map there are just
you know a gazillions of different
algorithms which goes inside and they
cooperate with each other and all of
this works because of the models so you
know models have a lot of properties
which are leveraged by these methods so
you know models are sparse there's a lot
of symmetries result of resonance in the
model there are some special structures
in the model like knapsack constraints
like some SAP flows and so on and all of
these things there are they are
leveraged by all of these techniques
which are implemented in the modern map
solar and you know what would be nice is
to have some sort of more formal formal
approach to this that we could say that
you know what is the property of a map
that can be exploited and how and will
it work or not as far as I know there
are not many if any theoretical results
in it will put put put disrespect so
just at the end a bit of self doubt so I
was talking about mips but are there
other techniques to model problems well
there are so you know sometimes you can
model a problem as a graph and then you
have some sort of out-of-the-box
algorithms like max flow minkos flow
however very often in practice what I
see in is that you know the problem is
almost like minkos flow it's like vincas
flow plus some twists and then this
twist is no longer you can no longer use
the min-cost flow you actually have to
resolve women on the other regime you
have a more rich syntax languages like
constraint programming so it's kind of
like prologue you might say so it has
more building blocks that you can use on
the other hand these I think are much
less trackable mathematically so it does
kind of seem that you know that the
mixing sure programming which is in the
between this X
pressive enough and two to be practical
and simple enough to be perhaps analyzed
theoretically and finally you know I
said that we don't really care about the
optimum is this true well just remark
let's go back to the very first example
I gave you where we were optimizing the
multi-dimensional multi been packing you
know this this objective actually spans
over 10 to the 6 and 10 to minus 3 so
it's like nine orders of magnitude so
this means that you know a gap of a very
very small gap might still mean that you
have a qualitatively different solution
so in some cases you actually do want to
wait for this bumps at the very end
because this means that your solution is
caused to be different and it's and it's
better for you that's about it um yeah
thank you very much and I open for
questions we have a few minutes for
questions so um I really like your talk
I liked your presentation and you made a
very compelling case that this
declarative nature of myth is a major
advantage particularly when you know you
have customers you're dealing with
problems that kind of our changed
underneath you while you're trying to
effectively solve them so I find this
extremely compelling I'm curious so I
mean how often this process that it
actually happened that of course you can
amend the NIP formulation but then cplex
agha roby goes like just doesn't do it
any longer because you know in an hour
work with miff we found that this
happens quite a bit especially when the
problem instances get challenging and
large and that what happens then is that
people start really looking a lot for
alternative models we are in reality
using a different configuration non
standard configurations of the MIPS
solver and can give you
a much easier solution so kind of two
questions how often does it blow up on
you and your experience that's out more
often how do you deal with it when it
happens okay so so the first question
that's hot it does happen quite often
that the you know the de client or the
team that we working with has new
features to add so it's it's more like
that we do not really change the model
we just extend it with additional
constraints or additional i'll change
the objective slide slide slightly so
this does happen usually it does not
really ruin the distance dissolving this
is case by case specific some
applications are more let's say time
tolerant in the sense that you know if
you go from one minute to five minutes
it's still okay so you can you can you
can do this if this is not the case
because sometimes it's not sometimes if
the new feature destroys your your model
in the sense that it's no longer being
efficiently solved then you can try to
be more aggressive with the
reformulation and then techniques such
as like model decomposition works very
very well usually so very often you know
we start with with with one big model
because at that point in time it was
simple to solve then you add features
the model starts being too hard to solve
so then you go back and say okay you
know you don't really need to solve this
at once we can like split it and have
two different models first of that then
solve this and again these are trackable
and super bowl practice so your
experience you don't fill up with cplex
to solve them after all without you know
decomposition which can lose your
personal technology depending on this
yeah so yeah we don't yeah we don't feel
all too much with the parameters you
should probably shut off a couple of
questions so one is if I try to solve
satisfiability with a MIP is it
competitive with the the satisfiability
zone um yes I would say not anymore
probably like the modern SAT solvers are
better than the observers at this like
by a huge factor um I think it depends
okay I don't have I don't have exact
knowledge in my head about this but I
think it depends on the on the program
as well and in the end you know
techniques that the SAT solvers use they
kind of go into MAPE solvers slowly they
diffuse into the solar so you know
eventually perhaps it's going to be
competitive in doing so permit me just a
quick comment because I happen to know
the answer to that a white well it's
honest and orders of magnitude and it
has been like that for a very long time
so I'm not aware of any practically
meaningful or interesting class of sad
instances that a nip solver could solve
you know even within a factor of a
thousand within competitive SAT solvers
okay the other question I had was that
one could imagine using nip solvers to
do something like deep learning right
because you could say that the
intermediate layer is a binary and then
the other Arizona's wait has anybody
tried that and is that a reasonable way
so I don't know if anybody tried that I
would say that it might be prohibitively
large so like in learning you have a lot
of examples that you learn from and this
would you know you would have to encode
all of that in your proficiency there's
no match I see yeah yeah
so how much kind of engineering black
art is there in the codes that that
combine all of these different
heuristics and apply them all to a given
problem that is he you could imagine it
applying one technique aggressively and
then the next or going back and forth
and so on and so forth how how are all
of these things put together so okay so
just to you know a disclaimer I did not
develop and the mix over so this is all
that I know by reading other papers and
other work but from what I know how
commercial observers are fine-tuned they
basically have a huge repository of all
different instances that their clients
are solving and they they just run it
experimentally with different settings
and then they choose the setting which
is the best across some domain or like
some problems so yeah it's just
experimental work
so from your experience when you were
running this myth solvers do you based
on your experience are you able to sort
of roughly predict how long it's going
to take on some given others I'm
wondering whether you know you can see
some problem instance in you're able say
oh this has certain features going to
make it take a long time are oh this
looks like a kind of thing it's going to
go click or bore you you feel like you
just can't tell until you run it like
this is going to take a long time or
quickly or you know what that curve is
going to look like on my particular
instance yeah so there's a very good
question yeah it's in general it's hard
to predict beforehand how long it's
going to take usually I'm I'm positively
surprised by the running times it is
sometimes possible to once you for
example have the first model you test it
and then you have the first the first
estimate how how how how it works then
it might be you might be able to predict
that if you add some additional feature
additional feature to the model you
might have some intuition of how it
should affect stuff so like one of the
features of the models that there are a
lot of symmetries usually so a lot of
solutions are equivalent so then if you
add features to the model which break
those symmetries this usually helps a
lot so these are techniques of modeling
which you know that they almost surely
will help you be more more efficient so
there are such things but in general you
know I think that we can still craft you
know malicious maps which are very small
and which would take you know weeks to
solve but in the end we don't really
care that much because these are
malicious and we never see them in
practice so I can't resist saying and
the album was setting me up here but a
substantial part of my talk on
Wednesdays would be exactly about
machine learning to print the rent in
Madison sorry machine learning to what
to predict the runtime of solvers for
for things like sad and nap so well for
example talk about being able to
certainly looking beyond size been
looking at viacom tutorial features of
an instance and within a well-defined
distribution it's quite predictable and
we seem to wandered off your talk so
maybe this is a good time to wrap up
date thanks very much